[Music]
this is not the Republican Party of five
years ago this is the party of Donald
Trump I'm here for one reason and one
reason only and that is that our
movement our party and America need four
more years of President Donald Trump in
the White House the program for this
year's meeting of American conservatives
is an echo chamber of trumps grievances
toward his political enemies and yet
another victory lap following his
impeachment acquittal in early February
the lone Republican who had voted to
convict Trump in the impeachment trial
Senator Mitt Romney saw his invitation
to CPAC withdrawn but his name still
came up to be jeered correct answer by
the way correct every time his name is
mentioned you should respond that way it
was a dramatic turnaround for Romney who
had previously won the CPAC unofficial
poll for president four times we now are
existing in a world of parties as teams
and they look at presidents as
quarterbacks and what we see is that
political parties are not allowing broad
or diverse coalition's the Republican
Party has its roots more than a century
and a half ago in the presidency of
Abraham Lincoln the president who
abolished slavery and stood for equal
rights
modern Republicans still proudly call
themselves the party of Lincoln but some
say Trump's Republican Party is the
antithesis of Lincoln's ideals we know
that many of you millions of you
struggle with what you are seeing every
day wondering what this party has become
and like you we know that what we're
witnessing is not normal it is not okay
it is not this is not a CPAC event but
the people on this stage in New York
call themselves the true Republicans
they're leaders of the Lincoln project a
group focused on promoting conservatism
while ending the Trump presidency but
they're renegades
I don't like them either by the way
Trump calls any Republican who opposes
him a never Trump er often the end of
their political career and at CPAC
disloyalty will not be tolerated
Heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera Washington
[Applause]